yo tout le monde sait squeeze tort start
et bien ça mais aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur un nouveau jeu d'horreur
dungeon nightmare et attention
apparemment un casque est grandement
conseillé bon appui sur l'espace sont
plus tard l'équipe moving ils savent qui
tue et qui il parlait ok donc djaouga
ces médias sont bons je vois absolument
rien or des lingots d'or chaque chambre
semble être en vie bon les mecs plus
glauque comme début du jeu c'est
possible 1 parce que là j'ai passé peur
allez c'est parti je fais je me fais qu
est ce que vous voyez pas là j'ai eu
très peur les bons réflexes qu'est ce
que c'était ok on va y aller tout doux
aux [ __ ] de fumée de merde [ __ ]
mais merde quoi alors qu'il sauva fer
nickel
j'aime bien la trajectoire qu'on a eu
des débuts du jeu on voi le mec qui a
tourné six enfants rois de prendre si
kouyate de bois et d'avancer ou qu'est
ce que c'est que ça à t fal fonde
trouver la sortie ça lâche son scarlett
source card sauce sociale allez une
petite bougie pour le fun et bien que
d'escrimeur en jeu c'est scandaleux
je te marche dessus moi je de marche
dessus de la terre il avait fait la
blague avant l'autre et ben moi tu me
l'as pas fait plus de chien et loup la
sortie où il a sorti parce qu'elle est
folle et à droite
ces partis ivoiriens mais [ __ ] voit
rien dit j'ai envie de faire ça mais je
passe pour un rendez-vous qu'on arrête
c'est bon mais qu'est-ce qui me tape mon
gars il m'a finalement fait la blague
ton pote l'a fait avant donc tu arrêtes
mon gars je suppose que dès que je me
retourne il s'était porté sur moi c'est
cette boîte d'accord qui met une
pression mais direct bon faut que
trouver la sortie
comment tu peux espérer trouver de
sortie si quoi à lui tu trouveras une
fête deux oublis tu m'avais pas un an
maintenant arrêtez avec votre blague les
mecs là c'est bon tu arrêtes avec ta
blague tu m'entends tu allais moi tu
l'aura voulu
bonjour sont aujourd'hui pas s'exercer
au pdi de tension à scarlet witch nazim
je vais pas passer ma vie à marcher à
reculons que c'est ridicule
je transpire dans vos t-shirts j'ai
trouvé un corps mort aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça que ça se termine
non ça se termine avec des squelettes
qui font des blagues nul ne la laisse
pas de trouver qui qui la blague labex
et ben voilà on sait déjà sur cette
chaise c'est ça la sortie un genre était
de faire le con ben slama bougie qui se
consume délicatement ont pendant ce
temps là on voit rien mais voir ja mais
je marche dans le noir comme ça mais à
ce point là je peux le faire en vrai
quoi c'est ça revient au même que de
jouer à ce jeu ce que même quand tu es
fatigué tu manges à cette vitesse non
non nickel moi c'est peut-être ça qui
nous poursuit sauf toi dit pas ça les
mecs si vous vous moquez prochaine à
droite tomtom dit nous tourner à droite
ok c'est bon maintenant maintenant
m'adapter aux cinq mètres tournez à
droite et ça lâche sheraton petit à
petit alors tu vas décédé décédé jcd
décédé bagata gueule à mes [ __ ] et
hop
ta gueule c'est là la sortie je le sens
là si c'est pas l'âge annoncent et là
c'est le décès plus tard va se prendre
des blagues de squelettes jour 2 j'ai
entendu des bruits cette nuit j'ai trop
peur de quitter cette pièce bateau va
peut-être me fais la quitter puis là tu
t'es laissé mourir mon gars donc bon
après je ça pour toi qu'est-ce qu'une
sorte de racailles qui passait par là et
carrier le mur en tête qu'en suivant le
il y avait un bruit c'est peut-être la
racaille qui venait de gratter contre le
mur je sais pas il y avait un accès un
petit 4 heures ici posée dans le noir on
te trouveras tu ne trouveras jamais je
sors la sortie à ckoi savoga sait si
jamais tu as peur tu peux faire un petit
peu
on est bien là un qui amène le 4 heures
la dr cette porte
je le sens [ __ ] c'est ma sortie
c'est pas ta sortie ferment cette porte
délicatement un os au [ __ ] mais y'a
combien de ce crime alors quoi est ce
que lis que même les chiens elle va
venir me faire peur aux foires et et aux
secousses auraient sorti vous avez
survécu à la première nuit tu te
réveilles dans 11h27
déjà cet homme est un [ __ ] de gros
dormeurs on peut le dire le donjon est
devenu plus fort comme une blague
deuxième nuit au nord le soleil sympa je
n'appuierai pas sur espace soit sûr
d'utiliser les bougies dans les chambres
sombre non je vais garder pour les
jambes bien lumineuse merci du conseil
aux artefacts found tatum apple a sorti
décédé au [ __ ] la fois objet raf
honnête mois de la part de dieu je
m'attendais à ça oh [ __ ] d'album
girafe
oui tu jeunes femmes peut-être dans
cette pièce
alors peut-être dans l'une des 28 août
oh ça c'est chiant quelqu'un qui entre
dans la pièce dans la pièce sort de la
pièce je veux dormir
c'est pourquoi je suis pas du tout
apprécié que je m'énerve c'est ridicule
c'est pourquoi le mec a fait qu il s'est
fait un kiff
on va faire un écran noir on va chanter
à sortir fumer et on va chanter un
centimètre de son oreille arriva il va
fortement appréciée je pense que j'ai
entendu une femme crier c'est toi marie
allez vous faire droite gauche droite
gauche droite
voilà après la géographie avec john nack
mer pour garder qu il est fatigué quand
on dirige schiste allongé par terre et
glisse marc en paix
oh marie bas rhinois tu tu étais là tout
près de moi je sors ta chaleur mari ne
me dis pas que au nom les frères jumeaux
blagueur non mais rester là discutent
blagueur partout quoi
j'accepte la proposition je te serre la
main et tu arrêtes tout gags diverses et
variées sur moi d'accord voilà c'est bon
marché conclu monsieur ton nom on avait
un accord ou navet et ou bloquées co
mais je suis bloqué d'accord jute est ce
que vous voyez je peux pas passer
éventuellement messieurs mais ce bloc
même sait qu ils peuvent pas parler il
ya le bruit à chaque fois et le bruit
qu'ils sont c'est de faire peur que je
te retourne et voit le squelette là le
truc qui marche pas du tout sur moi on
peut faire une musique quoi oui ils ont
gagné j'ai relancé le jeu c'est bon et
qu'est-ce qui ramassent des lingots d'or
c'est pour ça qu'à prix coursac m qu'il
ait soufflé qu'est ce qu'on s'en bat les
steaks de télé hbo d'or cotait poursuivi
par deux squelettes et titillant ronde
et pas cette petite fille manon autsai
et je pense que t'as pas compris
mais continuons parfait look un bon gros
moser cette part je m'en veux et ce
n'est peut-être pas tant que ça il a
voulu me faire peur pour malone et de la
sortie aide moi toi quand tu veux je
t'aide je veux pas te faire du bouche à
bouche je ne veux même pas touché
peut-être que la dose travaillera aux
côtés de la sueur et jetez pas décrier
non plus alors tu te détends direct je
m'attendais à ce qu'il soit le vieux mec
qui chuchote d'aller je me suis tapé son
frère jumeau quoi avait complètement
aussi fort de lui un donc soit son frère
jumeau
allez tout le monde debout à salut
femmes girafes tu ouvres les yeux ans
lève assez de la fumée très bien
par contre c'est un peu ridicule
laporta il s'est fait un kiff mon gars
elle aime le déclic de sa vie ça fait
des années que je suis ici à ne rien
faire à ne rien dire ça va mieux c'est
bon tu peux passer au au mari tu veux tu
m'as possèdent elles arrivent marima
possédée actuellement donc au [ __ ] ça
y est alors le mec qui chuchote le mec
qui crie d'accord le mec à qui on coupe
les couilles et je vous sors mais
restera toujours un pour hirvonen a lu à
la lumière la lumière presse space to
start night oui mais voilà les gens
c'est déjà fait une petite vidéo ici on
donne john natchez il était bien
flippant j'ai bien aimé même s'ils
avaient un peu trop de streamer je
trouve n'hésitez pas allez la vidéo ça
vous a plu ça fera plaisir on se
retrouve très bientôt une nouvelle vidéo
chat au monde pis